you had this experience that I mean I
think is absolutely
mind-blowing you were in a
production in London with the great
Vivian Lee
and uh you became friendly with her and
at one point they are
showing uh Gone With the Wind this is
many years later but they're showing the
film Gone With the Wind it was a a a a
re-release a new release you know that
have been smartened up and tied it up
and given new technology and because
you're friendly
she invites you to attend with her and
she you sit next to Vivian Lee you sit
next to Scarlet O'Hara as you watch Gone
With the Wind which is an experience
that I don't I I'll will never meet
anyone else who's had that experience
it's absolutely it's it's sitting with
hor and Wells and watching Citizen Cane
you know know it's I
and you said she at some point you could
see that she was crying yeah what
happened well by and by the way just to
get the the seating layout proper I was
on her left side on her right side was
her boyfriend who was a leading actor in
the company we were working for which
was the London Old Vic company on tour
we were only on tour we didn't ever play
in London and um I mean first of all
this invitation was wonderful the the
reason being that I was the humblest
member of the company I had been a last
minute inclusion two days before
rehearsals began I got this offer and
the producer the working Hands-On
producer was a very unpleasant
individual he found he chose me as his
one to go for M and he did once say in
front of the whole company Patrick we're
doing this in in in U in order of
billing and you're at the bottom so sit
down I mean you
know you wouldn't you don't you wouldn't
get away with that today I tried but no
you can't yeah is that quiet you oh he
he called me barely adequate the other
day he called me barely adequate really
yeah it was in a review the London time
look what happened to me you're going
places yes could be a testimonial oh my
God you finally given me something to
live
for so you're at this production yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm we're sitting
side by side and I am so excited and
thrilled and proud to be sitting
alongside her by the way in a dinner
jacket cuz we've been told by the way
when you go on this tour you must have
dinner jackets go there'll be a lot of
formal parties dinner jacket I'd never
owned a dinner jacket and I went to look
and I I couldn't possibly afford one
they were so expensive but on Charing
Cross Road there
was a a used garment men's used garment
shop and I went in and there was this uh
tuxedo and um it I don't know what it
was made of but it looked like a blanket
and it was and it was huge I think it
was a
blanket I think you got conned there a
slank it and so
I was sitting on one side of her and her
gorgeous boyfriend was sitting on the
other side of her wearing a fabulous
expensive suit and um I saw that she was
touching her
face quite
often and then finally she turned to me
and she took my hand and she said
Patrick I'm going to have to leave this
is so upsetting you see so many of these
lovely people I worked with are dead and
It's upsetting me so much so thanks for
sharing this I hope you enjoy the night
and she got up and she and John walked
out and uh I was so touched she could
have just left she didn't have to say
thank you for coming and it's very good
of you and explain to me why she was
crying she was a superstar oh God yeah
of of her day there was no actress today
that's ever been big
than than Vivian was and two Academy
Awards I think as well it wasn't just
that she was fabulous looking or that
she was a very very nice person but she
had a temper yeah I saw her once there
was a wonderful actress who I cannot
name but she is dead too um who was
playing a character in and she had a
leading role very important roles and uh
during the curtain call One night she
was on one side of Vivian and John was
on the other side I was the back on the
another row and
um uh as as this other actress Lean
Forward I heard her say something to the
other person who was leaning forward
with her I didn't hear what it said but
as she was standing
up Vivan who had just been presented
with a bouquet of flowers lifted it up
and hit her across the face with the B
flowers for speaking
yes and but she apparently she had said
something that viven didn't like didn't
like and um and she erupted then later
on we learned that she had um illnesses
yeah and they were very problematic and
indeed I think eight years later she
died of this um I believe she might have
had tuberculosis or something like that
I think it was a lung issue yes and she
also had what do they call that thing
that goes up and down anyway she had it
so she had bad couple of days and a week
of wonderful days and then a bad couple
of days and when she was having the bad
days you know what I don't we're talking
about VI oh you're talking about mental
illness yes yes yes the bipolar disease
bipolar yes that's right um which never
showed in her work anyway it was a great
privilege to have known her and she was
so kind and I celebrated my 25th first
birthday through a party and she came to
it oh my God none of the other producers
did but Vivian came and she gave me a
golden cotton
handkerchief which she had sprinkled
with the perfume that she always wore
she only wore one perfume which was
called Joy by Patu and it was wonderful
and for
years I could breathe Vivian in from the
handkerchief that she'd given me and
then I moved and went different places
and about 2 years ago I found it yes oh
good I was going to say if this thing is
missing wow I'm walking out now does it
still smell no oh the smell was gone but
the memories were still in place we
could get some Jupe
yes oh no you don't want to talk about
it's a cologne that men wear I've wore
it
once